Trump's new thing is he's calling  everybody fat he recently attacked his  own former Attorney General William Barr  by saying all he liked to do was eat all  he wanted to do was eat Trump recently  posted a picture of an obese man at a  buffet claiming that it was Chris  Christie the former Republican governor  of New Jersey saying here it's Chris  Christie trying to console himself at  the buffet I don't even know if the  picture was up Chris Christie and most  recently  um Maggie Haberman from The New York  Times in her forthcoming book writes  that Trump behind the scenes refers to  Florida Governor Ron DeSantis as fat  this is particularly weird because Trump  is obese Trump claims to be 6-3 and way  239 if you've seen him standing next to  Obama or Tom Brady you know Trump isn't  really 6'3 and he certainly doesn't  weigh 239 which according to BMI body  mass index makes Trump obese why is  Trump obsessed with attacking others for  their weight when Trump himself is obese